let's go next to our caller from the
three-two-three area code who is calling
today from three to three hey David some
Chino hey Gina and I just have a concern
hey I just have a concern about the
Rotax that that's being talked about by
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders sure
the thing is that I don't think that a
lot of the wealth that from billionaires
have is liquid enough for for it to be
taxed and I've heard a lot of countries
have tried the wall tax but it hasn't
worked the way they want it yes you're
actually you're correct I've mentioned
this before I've mentioned this before
and listen this is not about let's feel
sorry for billionaires whose wealth is
all tied up in stocks and corporate
ownership I'm not saying that it is a
practical consideration that other
countries have dealt with that wealth
taxes on people who don't necessarily
have a lot of cash can create situations
where they need to sell stocks in order
to be in compliance with the wealth tax
or do other things this is why it feels
as though lower hanging fruit would be
taxing capital gains at the same rate as
ordinary income because then you're
taxing the the gains on the wealth
rather than the the wealth itself which
may be held in illiquid assets now I I'm
guessing that there are counter
arguments but you are correctly stating
gee know that this has been a problem in
other countries and I completely agree
with you on that
yeah I don't I'm sure they think sir I
don't feel sorry for billionaires or
anything is just that I just I just
wanted to be taxed in an efficient way
there we get to the money we need for
the programs that we need total yeah I
mean it sounds like you and I are on the
same page thank you for the call yeah it
sounds like we're both on the same page
that we're not against a wealth tax
morally and we're not against what it's
trying to do and we don't we're not
against reducing inequality but we have
some concerns about the implementation
of such attacks